[Musique]
françaises français
on vous a dit et vous en êtes
profondément convaincu que notre pays ne
peut sortir de la crise que si nous
consentons tous à faire des efforts
[Musique]
ces efforts
vous les faites chacun dans son domaine
multiplie les états individuels et je me
plaisent à le salir
malheureusement tous ces efforts
magnifique sont trop souvent gaspillée
à partir de maintenant je vous invite
non seulement à poursuivre et à
intensifier vos efforts mèze à les
conserver
à l'instant même où je vous parle des
buts une grande collecte nationale des
efforts de tous les français fait bon
accueil aux collecteurs d'efforts muni
d'une carte officielle
bonjour monsieur collector vous en
prison près ma famille et moi même vous
allez remettre le fruit de ses forces à
lens
[Musique]
vos efforts sont les bienvenus
en france nous n'avons pas de pétrole
mais nous avons des efforts est la
preuve que la mise en commun de tous ces
efforts constitue une réelle source
d'énergie le fameux satin portées par ce
petit document tourné à l'institut des
efforts
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'utilisation de l'effort en
tant qu'énergie nouvelle en est encore
au stade de la recherche
mais demain l'effort animera toute la
production grâce à la banque de l'effort
à la banque de l'effort chacun pourra
aller déposer ses efforts et sa famille
[Musique]
ce capital énergétique abondant et
renouvelables constituera pour la france
une richesse naturelle fabuleux
fini les pipelines pétrole fait ni les
câbles électriques
il vous suffira d'approvisionner trains
et les avions avec vos valises bourrées
et d'efforts directement utilisables
et alors
[Musique]
françaises français la voie royale d'un
avenir prodigieux s'ouvre devant nous
encore un effort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]